welcome on board this advancing West
Coast service to Lancashire in the north
west of England calling at Preston
Lancaster
and on to Pendle a parliamentary
constituency which has long voted
conservative but there are people here
that now have problems with their party
we have watched an absolute Rubble yeah
with no discipline
charging around some of them and Brandi
neutral I think it could do with a good
shackle the last few years are just just
blowing it out of the water for me from
the cost of living economically we're in
a bit of a turmoil time we need more
investment I'll ask for more investment
up in the north to Illegal immigration
for all these people put up in hotels
which is I believe is six million a day
they're not migrants it's an invasion
force and the Health Service I think the
main thing is the NHS to be quite honest
almost 250 miles south in Westminster
this is the first session we have with
the prime minister of 2023. the pm today
grilled on those subjects intent on
telling MPS and voters he's heard them
and is trying to get on with the job on
the economy we are on track with all of
those obr forecasts inflation to be more
than halved by the end of the year and
on the NHS all our commitments are cut
waiting lists there's absolutely
Paramount and protected but it was right
getting on with it but his plan to stop
illegal Boat Crossings undoubtedly the
hardest and most controversial of policy
areas to crack use of the word Invasion
to describe the small boats problem I
think look it's very clear that the
scale of the problem is significant and
growing
fend in the language and the provisions
of his new immigration Bill too with no
detention exemption for children who
make illegal Crossings another thing we
want to create a pull factor to make it
more likely that children are being
making this very perilous journey in
conditions that are appalling I don't
think that's the right thing to do but
it's the people and the voters here in
Pendle that will be the judge of what's
right the first test at the local
elections in may lose control of the
council you do you're unfortunately you
do
bath Rigby Sky News in Pendle Lancashire